this animation is brought to you by
skillshare an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes for
creative people
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity
if you are pregnant you can take folic
acid to help prevent certain birth
defects in your baby
folic acid and folate are two forms of
the same b
vitamin folate is the form that occurs
naturally in foods
while folic acid is the man-made form
added to multivitamins and fortified
foods
your body needs folic acid to help make
new cells
including brain cells
blood cells
and dna and rna the genetic material
inside your cells during pregnancy
you need even more folic acid because
your baby's body
needs it too folic acid helps your
baby's brain and spinal cord
develop normally
taking folic acid can significantly
reduce the risk
of neural tube defects in your
developing baby
called an embryo at this stage
the neural tube begins as a tiny
oval-shaped piece of embryonic tissue
which folds into a tube about 28 days
after conception
when this tube closes properly it
continues to develop into your baby's
brain and spinal cord
if the neural tube does not close due to
the lack of folic acid in your diet
your baby may have a neural tube defect
such as spina bifida
or anencephaly in spina bifida
the neural tube fails to close at the
bottom
as a result the parts of the spine that
enclose
and protect the lower spinal cord do not
completely form
allowing the cord to protrude children
with this defect
often require surgery and have permanent
disabilities
including leg paralysis developmental
delays
and nervous system problems
in the condition called anencephaly the
neural tube fails to close at the top
preventing large parts of the brain and
skull from developing completely
babies with this defect are unable to
live and usually die
before birth or soon after
folic acid may also protect against
other birth defects
such as cleft lip and palate
and atrial septal defect which is when a
hole
between the right and left upper
chambers of the heart
fails to close during development
because the neural tube develops so
early in pregnancy
often before a woman knows she's
pregnant experts recommend all women who
are able to become pregnant
take a daily multivitamin containing 400
micrograms of folic acid
every day during pregnancy the need
increases to
600 micrograms of folic acid each day
experts recommend you take this
multivitamin in addition to the food
folate in your diet
because your body does not absorb folate
found naturally in food
as easily as the man-made folic acid
caregivers will often prescribe even
1000 micrograms of folic acid daily
to assure these minimal levels are
covered even more may be required in
some groups of women
including those with previous
miscarriages and those women deficient
in a folic acid metabolic enzyme talk
with your caregiver about the optimal
dose for you
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creatives
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads and they're
always launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
if you want to learn how to use the same
software programs we use at nucleus
skillshare has hundreds of courses for
you on cinema 4d
adobe after effects and zbrush they
offer courses on how to create
micrograph images in c4d
so your cellular animations look
realistic and cinematic
and much much more take advantage of
skillshare's free trial for premium
membership by clicking the link below in
the video description
sign up and explore your creativity